right across from the Mirage is this  what some are calling the great  grasshopper invasion of 2019 has taken  over Las Vegas within the past week  these harmless insects have migrated in  swarms covering doors even testing their  luck on the Vegas Strip  state officials attribute the migration  to the weather when we have a wet winter  or spring these things build up and then  we'll have flights about this time of  the year migrations and they'll move  northward experts say these grasshoppers  are known as pallid winged and should  fly out of the area over the next  several weeks that prime rib special for  1295 doesn't look so a delicacy right  don't they just fried those yeah